في سياقي التوتر والحوار نفى لكرمنت اي
تهديدات مدعومه باستخدام الصواريخ صدرت عن
الرئيس بوتين خلال مكالمه هاتفيه مع رئيس
الوزراء البريطاني السابق برس جونسون
وكانت جونسون قال في مقابله صحفيه ان
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين هدده بصاروخ
لكن الامر بدا على سبيل التلاعب والمراره
باريس لا اريد ايذاءك بصاروخ سيستغرق
الامر دقيقه واحده او شيئا من هذا القبيل
لكن بسبب نبرته الهاتف التي كان يستخدمها
اعتقد انه كان يراوغ لدافع للتفاوض قال
لبورس انت تقول ان اوكرانيا لن تنضم
للنيتو في اي وقت قريب ما الذي يعني في اي
وقت قريب قالها بالانجليزيه واجبته
انها لن تنضم للنيتو في المستقبل المنظور
بوتن بالتهديد بقتله بصاروخ ورد الكريم
للعرائس معنا من لندن مراسله الجزيره مينا
حربلو ومن موسكو مدير مكتب الجزيره زوور
شاوش مرحبا بكما مينا سنبدا معك في اي
سياق وردت هذه التصريحات لجونسون ولماذا
تاخر الى الان الى الاعلان عنها
وهذه التصريحات التي تصرح بها الرئيس
الوزراء البريطاني السابق برج جونسون تاتي
في سياق وثائقي اعادته في سلسله من ثلاث
حلقات يبداوا بثته مساء اليوم وهذه
التصريحات الجديد فيها هو انا رئيس
الوزراء البريطانيا السابق يقول او يزعم
بان الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين هدد
ضربه بساروخ وقال له بانني لا اريدك ولكن
بصاروخ واحد الا يتطلب الامر دقيقه واحده
فقط او شيء من هذا القبيل حسب التعبير برج
جونسون جونسون كان قد اجرى محادثه وصفها
بالطويله جدا وغير العاديه مع الرئيس
الروسي الذي من بوتين همم قبل الغزو
الروسي لاوكرانيا وبعد زياره الزياره التي
قام بها جونسون لكي في بدايه فبراير من
العامه الماضي كان يحاول الحديث مع رئيس
الروسي من اقناعه بالعزوف والتراجع عن غزو
اوكرانيا وكان قد تحدث معه خلال هذه
المحادثه حول اا يعني الرد الذي سيكون من
قبل حلف الناتو لان بوتين كان قد صرح له
بانه يخشى من توسع حلف ان يتعلى حدود
روسيا وهو المعهد ما حد هدد برج جونس بانه
يحدث وهو ما حدث فعلا بعد انتقال قوات حلف
انيته الى الحدود مع روسيا من اجل الدفاع
عن اوكرانيا والدفاع عن الجناح الشرق
لاوروبا ماذا عن التعامل الروسي مع هذه
التصريحات
نعم المتحدث باسم الكربلائي ان كان واضحا
حينما وصف كلام بولس جونسون بانه كلام كذب
وقال اما ااا باريس جونسون يكذب عن قصد او
انه لم يفهم ما قاله الرئيس الروسي وهذا
معتاد على طريقه التعامل مع تحديدا
المسؤولين على البريطانيين بسكوف قال انها
بوتين قال ابلغ
هواجس روسيا في شان احتمال ضم اوكراني الى
حلف الناتو نشر صواريخ هجوميه هذا يعني
موسكو ستكون مستهدفه في غضون بضع دقائق
الامر الذي لم تقبله روسيا طبعا باريس سان
جونسون هو ربما من اكثر الشخصيات التي
تحظى بانتقاد وسخريه من الجانب الروسي ان
كان على المستوى الرسمه على مستوى
الاعلاميذ كان وزيرا للخارجيه وحتى حين
كان رئيسا الوزاره تعتبر انا بريطانيا هي
ربما الاكثر تشددا الى جانب الولايات
المتحده في موقفها ازاء الهواجس الروسيه
المتعلقه
الام ومسات انضمام اوكرانيا ومن مساله
ايضا همم اكثر الداعمين لنظام كيف كما
تسميه موسكو في هذه المواجهه التي تجري
الان على الاراضي الاوكرانيا
في لندن مينا حربلو